For a few hours in May 2016, for the first
time in more than a century,
Britain was burning zero coal to generate
electricity.
None at all.
All the coal-fired power plants
were turned off.
And this here is one of the reasons why.
Welcome to the Griffin Wind Farm in Scotland.
68 turbines, more than 150 megawatts of capacity.
And the turbines rotate and trim the blades
to track the wind in real time.
At full output, this can power entire cities
just from the wind.
But as the world moves to renewable energy,
we’ve got a little bit of a problem.
Because coal, oil, gas, and nuclear stations
are basically just giant boilers.
They take water, they heat it up,
that turns to steam,
the steam gets forced through a massive turbine
which rotates and generates power.
When I say turbine, I don’t mean like the
blades here,
I mean hundreds of tonnes of steel rotating
thousands of times a minute.
And all those turbines, all around the grid,
rotate in sync with each other.
After gearing, they all move at
50 cycles a second.
60 in America.
All perfectly in time: one slows down, they
all slow down.
One speeds up, they all speed up.
And that is what stops your lights
from constantly flickering.
Because electricity supply has to always match
demand, pretty much exactly.
There isn't a battery in the world big enough
to store power on a national scale.
So if a power station suddenly falls off the
grid for some reason,
then where’s that supply going to come from?
And the answer is the kinetic energy that’s
already in those turbines,
in that spinning thousands of tonnes of steel
around the country.
Homes and factories will literally suck the
kinetic energy out of that turbine
to cover the gap, starting to slow it down.
But that won’t cause a problem
for 60 seconds or so,
and in that time the National Grid
Control Centre will, I don’t know,
throw another nuclear rod on the barbie
and up the power output from other stations.
They'll cover the demand.
But, well, that relies on
having enough rotational mass,
enough system inertia, as it’s called.
And here, in this turbine?
Well, you can see.
There’s no hundreds of tonnes
of spinning steel,
just some blades, a bit of metal,
and some circuitry that feeds the power into
the grid at the right frequency.
If the whole grid were running on
just wind and solar,
there's no rotational mass.
There's no grid stability.
The minute that supply and demand mismatch,
breakers would trip,
and the whole thing would fall apart.
Now there are some
possible solutions to this.
Pumped hydro storage
has been around for a while,
which is where you have two lakes
at different heights.
When you’ve got too much power,
you pump water up,
and when you’ve got not enough, you drop
it back down again through generators.
But that takes seconds or minutes
to kick in.
There’s also some experiments going on with
things like molten glass storage,
compressed air storage, and flywheels,
but they’re all experimental at the minute
and not particularly efficient.
The actual solution may come from somewhere
a little unexpected.
Because yes, wind is replacing coal and oil,
but it’s also replacing petrol, the gasoline
that you put in your car.
And as more and more and electric cars
get connected to the grid, well,
you’ve got a load of quite large batteries
with computers.
Your car could sell power
back to the grid in real-time,
second by second, as it’s needed.
Combine that with smart appliances and meters
that can watch the grid
and work out when would be the best time to
turn on your air-conditioning and fridge is,
and you have a grid that does
a lot of the balancing itself.
Yes, we will probably always need a
turbine somewhere,
some big spinning mass of steel to cover
the little glitches second to second,
but the solution to balancing a power grid
is not what we thought it was 20 years ago.
It’s not big, monolithic batteries.
It’s millions of small ones
up and down the country.
Thank you very much to all the team from SSE
who have helped get me, and my team,
up on top of this wind turbine.
I am incredibly grateful.
They have gone above and beyond to help out,
so please,
have a look at the links in the description
for more about them,
and about the Griffin Wind Farm.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]